et en matière de tourisme cette année
tous les indicateurs sont décidément au
vert la navigation fluviale connaît une
véritable embellie grâce aux
plaisanciers partout le long des
rivières d'ile-de-france les touristes
étrangers des danois des anglais
principalement ont découvert sous un
autre angle la région la batellerie
plutôt mal en point a trouvé là une
bouffée d'oxygène
reportage sur les canaux de seine et
marne paul rick marie-paule rigal didier
morel cloud de varennes bonjour bonjour
monsieur je suis avalant je suis à la
gare d'eau comment il est plus s'il vous
plaît
ça va être bon pour vous là dans cinq
minutes ça va être
je me sens les appels de ce type à l'art
et son équipe en ont reçu plus de 8000
depuis le début de l'année la navigation
fluviale se porte bien depuis 1980 les
plus de varennes sur scène ouvre
généreusement ses portes à de plus en
plus de bateaux de plaisance de
plaisance il ya vingt ans il y en avait
peut-être un ou deux par semaine
maintenant on fait facilement une
dizaine par jour
la plaisance figure dans la catégorie du
risque devrait elle se démocratise en
france les autorités territoriales font
de plus en plus d'investissements
histoire de récolter quelques gouttes de
cette manne venue des eaux
on s'aperçoit que les communes ont fait
des efforts vnf a fait des efforts il ya
des endroits pour stationner pour
s'arrêter pour les petits bateaux on
peut on peut s'arrêter dans un village
qui a aménagé une berge qui a mis des
pieux et qui nous permettent de
s'amarrer et puis d'aller dans le
village aller faire des courses le
réseau d'une de france représente 600 km
de voies navigables la location des
bateaux et gérés exclusivement par des
sociétés privées un frein à cet
engouement le prix de deux mille neuf
cent à 10 mille francs la semaine de
quoi décourager cette formule de
vacances nour a séduit cette année que
30% de la clientèle française